bonjour à tous vous allez poursuivre cet
après midi une audition sur les rythmes
scolaires unis sont organisées par la
mission commune d'information sur cette
réforme des rythmes scolaires
cette mission a pour objet d'étudier la
mise en place de cette réforme vous le
savez polémique
une réforme qui vise à mieux répartir
les heures de classe sur la semaine elle
est pour l'instant appliquées dans 4000
communes en france
voilà on se retrouve tout de suite après
voilà mes chers collègues toujours dans
le cadre de nos éditions dans la mission
de la commission commune d'information
sur la réforme des rythmes scolaires je
souhaite la bienvenue à monsieur
françois testu qui est chrono
psychologue spécialiste des rythmes
biologiques
monsieur testud nous nous procédons delà
de la façon suivante au niveau
méthodologie vous nous présenter votre
votre sujet ensuite je donnerai la
parole à madame le rapporteur pour des
questions qu'elle pourra vous posez et
les réponses ensuite que vous pourrez
lui apporter et dans un deuxième temps
ce sont nos collègues qui vous poseront
plusieurs questions simultanément auquel
vous aurez le temps de répondre bien
évidemment le temps qui nous est imparti
sur cette audition est de 1h je vous
donne la parole et je vous remercie de
votre présence parmi nous monsieur
bonsoir chers collègues
j'avoue que je travaille un peu en
france parce que je savais pas trop sur
quel aspect abordé la question parce que
bien de précision donc je vais aborder
la question qui nous préoccupe et qui
nous réunit aujourd'hui sous l'éclairage
plutôt scientifique sous l'éclairage
d'un chrono psychologue peau
chronobiologistes mais je vais revenir
revue j'ai bien entendu mais qui
s'occupe des rythmes biologiques bros et
ça n'a aucune importance c'est pas grave
on se comprendre et je donnerai un petit
peu mon avis et quelques pistes qui ont
déjà été suivi en partie mais qui mérite
d'être encore poursuivi en matière
d'aménagement du temps d'où le titre que
j'ai essayé de donner et j'avoue que je
suis agréablement surpris malgré toutes
les difficultés qu'il peut y avoir en
matière de d'aménagement nouveau du
temps le constater que cette question
devienne question centrale en matière
d'éducation et surtout quand on a
cherché pendant 30 ans et sans faire
dans la plaisanterie des chercheurs qui
cherchent et trouvent pas et qu'on a
trouvé quelques résultats et que ces
résultats bien son suivi d'applications
à c'est d'autant plus agréable
on peut dire ainsi c'est que la question
des replays de vie des enfants et plus
particulièrement les rythmes scolaires
est une question qui a été l'objet de
nombreux débats
de nombreux échanges pas toujours avec
les mêmes partenaires d'ailleurs j'ai pu
constater d'ailleurs que vous avez
sollicité tous azimuts au niveau les
intervenants ce qui vous donne quand
même un panorama assez importants et des
positions retenu par les uns et les
autres et ce débat était récurrent et
mais on restait au stade du débat
et ils durent depuis un bon bout de
temps battle moment là je les amenais
histoire pour l'anecdote de c'est un
rapport tout vétuste
le rapport de la fatigue écoliers
français dans le système scolaire actuel
de rapport réalisé par le professeur
debré associé au docteur daniel douadi
rapport qui date de 1962 je tiens à
préciser que si nous l'avions tous lui
et si nous presser prédécesseur l'avait
lu et bien je suis pas sûr du tout que
nous soyons là en ce moment les yeux
parce que les suprêmes bon sens et a
plein de bonnes préconisations et puis
les rapports se sont succédé et vos
collègues de l'assemblée nationale eh
bien on rédige est aussi un dents au
sein de leur commission des affaires
culturelles un rapport d'information ok
rythme à l'école bas et puis nous avons
eu des ministres successifs pas
forcément d'abord plutôt que l'autre qui
se sont préoccupés la question de l'eau
je ne peux que et aujourd'hui nous
sommes en plein dans le sujet on tape
dans le dur alors je dirais en entrée
que aux matières l'aménagement du temps
scolaire n'existe pas de solution idéale
et qu'il s'agit de trouver le moins
mauvais des compromis entre le respect
du développement de des enfants des
élèves le respect de leur santé de leur
rythme et tout en sachant que l'élève
constitue un tout il n'est pas qu'elle
ait ville est aussi l'enfant de ses
parents est aussi le participant à des
activités péri et extrascolaires il est
aussi qui celui qui de temps en temps un
bien cuit et de sole et le pouvoir vivre
avec ses copains tranquillement mais bon
ça dans notre société ses positions et
puis il faut dire aussi que ce compromis
se fait donc dans le respect de l'enfant
mais aussi dans le respect des besoins
des adultes dans une société en pleine
évolution et il est clair que le le
cadre de l'école d'aujourd'hui doit pas
être celui d'hier
d'où la nécessité de cette modification
mais qui dirait aménagement du temps
scolaire dit automatiquement
réaménagement du temps péri et extra ce
que et à l'entrée quand je suis arrivé
tout à l'heure c'était très très
intéressant de voir que les gens son
passé n'est ce point la personne qui
contrôle les 4-10 indiqué me dit mais
alors qu'est ce que vous en pensez
oui j'en pense que du bien je vous dis à
mesure où les travaux de recherche sont
appliquées enfin où on en tient un peu
content c'est une bonne chose
ouais mais dis moi mes enfants je vous
aime bien qu'il fasse sa tasse à ça ça
ça va je dis oui monsieur mais quand
vous libérer du temps il faut savoir
quoi en faire après il faut canton dé
densifie la journée je préfère
d'identifier bien j'ai utilisé autrefois
le terme alléger
eh bien il faut savoir ce qu'on met à la
place du temps libéré bref en vous
disant tout ceci je viens de définir
très simplement les deux axes de la
refondation de l'école et plus
particulièrement de la réforme des
rythmes scolaires est bien le premier
c'est le respect des rythmes de vie
l'enfant de l'enfant dans son entité et
le deuxième c'est la reconnaissance et
l'organisation des activités
complémentaires éducative ce sont les
deux axes et celui qui aujourd'hui pose
plus problème
je crois à mon avis c'est le deuxième
bon malheureusement je vais peut-être
pas rentrer dans le deuxième je vais
surtout m'intéresser au premier qui lui
aussi avant qu'on s'attaque à la
complémentarité négative était un sujet
très polémique jeune connu l'époque
héroïque où on se battait comme des
chiffonniers entre guillemets avec la
subjectivité qui l'accompagnent ce débat
arbitre r c'était samedi ou dimanche
euh non samedi jean cipolla samedi ou
mercredi
c'était quatre jours où kate joigny
c'était bon bref
alors si on peut plus continuer ainsi et
je crois qu'il est nécessaire que la
conscience à sion qui a déjà existé
perdu vous en êtes des artisans et je
vous en remercie
et c'est une nécessité mais cela ne
suffit pas je crois qu'il est nécessaire
aussi de tenir compte de ces fameux
travaux et ses travaux relèvent de là
alors on va voir si ça fonctionne nous
vous savez ma testud impro relève de la
chronobiologie et de la
chronopsychologie regard des bons à la
chronobiologie vous en avez la
définition c'est un mot bien savant qui
a pour objet l'étude des rythmes durable
d'ensemble biologique dont la période et
l'amplitude certificative de
statistiques se maintenant durandeau
cycle lorsque les facteurs
environnementaux sont constants fermez
le ban donc ça c'est une définition
incontournable et alors il est toujours
bon d'avoir un petit chronobiologistes
chez soi pour justifier telle ou telle
politique
bon c'est pas ça le rôle des
chronobiologistes n'est pas là juste
pour éclairer et non pour faire prendre
parti telle ou telle personne deuxième
discipline la chronopsychologie dont je
considère être l'un des artisans
bien que vont mettre à penser en la
matière fut paul fraisse ceux qui me
connaissent et psychologie savent que
c'est le père de la psychologie
expérimentale et rigoureuse et
scientifique qui a pour objet l'examen
des variations périodiques
comportementale et qui étudie les
changements du comportement pour eux
mêmes je rappelle que définition même de
la psychologie c'est l'étude
scientifique des comportements donc le
saut n'est pas des paroles comme dit ces
braves gens verbal
ce sont bien des faits établis
scientifiquement pas la méthode ou
mental est là on a introduit la
dimension temporelle
donc c'est cette chronologie permet et
cette chronologie permet de savoir ce
que sont les rythmes de vie des jeunes
d'en savoir un peu plus
quelles sont les conséquences de tel ou
tel aménagement sur le développement de
l'enfant sur les comportements des
jeunes dans et en dehors de l'école là
c'est difficile le connaître
scientifiquement les travaux
connaître les comportements d'hommes et
d'analyser les travaux afin je vais
avant de présenter ses résultats je
voudrais en lever une ambiguïté une
habileté qui est liée à l'expression
rythme scolaire
en effet cette expression à au moins
deux possibilités de définition la
première c'est à dire les rythmes
scolaires ce sont ni plus ni moins que
les calendriers scolaires et les emplois
du temps les vacances et donc lesquels
en estuaire deuxième définition est plus
proche du jeune il lui ce sont les
variations périodiques biologique
biologie physique et psychologique
propre à l'enfant et adolescents en
situation scolaire
ces deux défis sont j'allais dire anti
le rythme non mais complémentaires c'est
à dire que l'enfant
le jeune vie dans son environnement
scolaire périscolaire scolaire avec ses
propres et en même temps il vit dans un
environnement qui lui même et rythmique
l'alternance des vacances alternance des
temps de repos avec les temps scolaires
constituent une réplique cité qui est a
été créée de toutes pièces par les
adultes et jusqu'à aujourd'hui
vannes on exagère de pied jusqu'à il ya
quatre cinq ans encore
eh bien on appréhendait que cette
dimension contrôlé par les élites et on
avait quelques informations par ci par
là
donc voilà alors maintenant passons au
concret de ces résultats je vous fais
grâce de toutes les méthodologies
utilisées en matière de chronos écologie
sachez quand même que la soutient que je
vais vous présenter s'appuie à peu près
sur 40
l'observation ou le testing de quarante
mille jeunes pas en même temps
bien évidemment parce que comme cette
jeune discipline naissante les moyens je
peux vous faire la quête à la sortie les
moyens étaient quand même assez limité
mais enfin heureusement que les
collectivités locales les ministères
temps en temps trouver des fonds de
tiroirs pour aider cette collecte de
données et donc ça représente carpi
l'enfant avec une méthode contrôlé avec
quatre applications statistiques
c'est-à-dire que quand je vous présente
et du coup ça veut dire que derrière et
une vérification statistiques ça fait
pas tout les statistiques m'enfin ça
nous permet d'avoir des rails de
sécurité dans nos affirmations alors il
y à des rythmes qu'il convient de
respecter en priorité et je me suis
sciemment limitée à 3 mais si vous posez
la question je pourrais vous en donner
l'autre mais je crois qu'il ya des
priorités alors bon sens vous n'aviez
pas tout à fait tort qu'ils allaient
rendre chrono psychologue s'occupe des
rythmes biologiques de temps en temps
parce que j'ai mis en premier le sommeil
c'est rythme veille sommeil qui est
incontournable
et puis en second des variations
journalières de la vigilance et
l'activité intellectuelle ça c'est
nouveau ça c'est nouveau dans la
connaissance
or public entre guillemets et
troisièmement des périodes annuelles de
faible résistance et quand on tient
compte de tout cela eh bien à mon avis
on arrive à des réformes comme celles
que nous avons aujourd'hui alors le
sommeil je vais pas vous faire raconter
des histoires à dormir debout
c'est très lourd merci mais c'est un
enfant un jeune manque de sommeil
régulièrement pas occasionnellement
tantôt lions de la c est ce qu'au niveau
de commandes y rêve de
du soleil nocturne eh bien ces
comportements qui vont suivre vont est
inadaptée comportement en classe mais
aussi en dehors de l'école en classe a
va se manifester par des comportements
d'inattention de d'agacement
d'énervement c'est là aussi les
collègues enseignants et ou alors
carrément du cou avait requis contre
d'apathie de désintérêt de rêvasseries
entre guillemets loyer al basri ça veut
tout dire
et ceci nous l'avons observé en classe
par des procédures de l'observation
systématique des comportements en grâce
vous fait grâce là aussi de la
méthodologie mais respectez soleil c'est
facile de lire c'est beaucoup plus
difficile de le respecter
d'abord une très grande inégalité des
jeunes des enfants par rapport au
sommeil inégalités dans l'âge de
disparition de la sieste les enfants à
12 ans ils n'ont plus besoin de dormir
forte je te les rme trois ans les
enfants qui n'ont plus besoin de donner
à ces styles éprouve plus besoin swaps
et les petits l'envers de sieste puis
vous avez l'autre à 6 ans ils ont encore
besoin de pilota 60 ans ils ont encore
besoin données et puis ainsi de suite
la cession des grands dormeurs de c'est
évidemment les durées diminue et puis
vous avez même chose au niveau du
sommeil de nuit parce que vous avez des
enfants qui éprouvent ils sont rares
mais ils existent quand même qu'ils
éprouvent le besoin d'éviter au lit le
soir
bien qu'ils aient dormi à la sieste et
là il ya doute oublié du grand nord
borde csd grand dormeur de nuit des
grands dormeurs et toutes les
combinaisons sont possibles et là
arriver à trouver le moins mauvais
créneau la moins mauvaise des solutions
en matière du respect du soleil c'est
difficile pour les parents parce qu'en
plus vous avez des parents qui arrivent
tard le soir quand ils arrivent tard le
soir mais qu'est ce qui se passe et il
était chaud pour aller récupérer leurs
enfants trie mes déchets des nounous
chez la grand-mère je ne sais où ils
n'ont qu'une loi c-2 de laver l'enfant
lui donner à manger
le coucher et hop c'est fini et dans le
meilleur des cas on va peut-être avoir
une petite comptine mais ça c'est un peu
un rêve
et souvent on met deux fois pour que
c'est le plus vite pour l'embellissement
la télévision dans les champs je veux
pas vous faire pleurer vous raconte
l'histoire de causette mais c'est quand
même un peu ça et dans certains milieux
pas partout heureusement mais donc ce
sommet il difficile à souhaiter pour les
parents mais difficile aussi à l'école
parce que d'abord à l'école il ya
plusieurs freins à ce respect du sommeil
pour la sieste il ya d'avoir des freins
matériel faut les locaux ou un endroit
isolé il faut du personnel parce que
l'idéal il faut que la une personne qui
garde qui qui qui s'occupe des enfants
qui est un oeil éclairer sur sur les
enfants c'est souvent c'est en
maternelle ce surtout à la maternelle et
pinceaux c'est uniquement et c'est aussi
le problème de l'état d'esprit c'est pas
dans l'air du temps de dormir
aujourd'hui avec je vois ce qui se passe
pour les enfants de maternelle lors ce
qu'on demande 2 on en est quand même des
cahiers de compétences on en est à des
parents voire des enseignants voire des
inspecteurs qui disent attendait il faut
qu'ils soir mais il faut viser les
prérequis oui c'est vrai mais on prépare
pas dès la maternelle les nauru centrale
mais malheureusement c'est ancré ça
aujourd'hui et j'ai j'ai quand même
entendu je ne vendent pas des parents
qu'ils disaient mes skis c'est lire à la
fin de la maternelle des bois oui tant
mieux si à vis à vis attendu laissé pas
l'objectif dès maintenant et donc c'est
très compliqué de respecter alors aussi
inégalités par rapport à l'âge de
disparition de la sieste voulait dit
donc négliger par rapport à l'âge de
disparition d'agnès et puis inégalités
par rapport aux jurés donc là il ya un
prêt alors ce sommeil c'est l'hommage il
faut absolument qu'il soit respecté
plusieurs travaux en montrent l'utilité
et montrent le lien qui peut y avoir
entre les progrès
cognitif et le sommeil ainsi bon durée
de sommeil de moins de 10 heures
multiplie par 3 pour le tout petits de
maternelle deux ans et demi à 6 ans le
risque de faibles performances scolaires
à 6 ans donc la saison des travaux
étrangers la plupart anglais ou
américains on démontre aussi une
amélioration spectaculaire du
comportement à des performances
scolaires après une augmentation du
temps de sommeil
et puis je voulais quand même faire un
petit point précis après il est démontré
que de ne pas avoir de riscle de coucher
régulier et là aussi c'est important
le mot régler va revenir dans mon propos
est bien est liée à des scores cognitif
significativement moins élevé si on
donne la possibilité aux enfants
et si de dormir c'est pas le problème de
leur imposer puisque j'ai dit toute la
vie qui avaient besoin et locales
c'est seulement leur laisser la
possibilité comme il est indiqué la bien
on voit que les enfants peuvent ajouter
aussi enlever des esprits l'idée que si
on dort on apprend bien non non ça je
vais essayer d'apprendre l'anglais en
mettant des bandes magnétiques léger
théorie comme ça pendant votre sommeil
ça fonctionne pas par contre le sommeil
permet la récupération de la fatigue
physique voire mental mais c'est pas les
premiers les acquisitions ne se font pas
comme ça peut être un problème de
consolidation et encore c'est pas
démontrée donc ça c'est la première et
me citer à respecter et c'est vrai
aujourd'hui on s'attaque aux primaires
mais c'est vrai aussi pour le secondaire
nous avons des travaux qui montrent que
les gaillards gaillarde
du collège dans une troisième voie eh
bien parfois on les moments de
somnolence après midi et qui sont
renforcés souvent par le travail qu'ils
font le soir chez eux
encore une problématique liée aux
rythmes scolaires mais je m'égare je
reviens sur le prix mais puisque c'est
le secteur qui nous intéresse
aujourd'hui alors deuxième élément 2e
rep licite et qu'il convient de
respecter bien sûr les variations
journalières de la vigilance et de
l'activité rituel on sait aujourd'hui le
grâce aux travaux de chronopsychologie
dans la journée généralement quand la
semaine était une semaine de quatre
jours et demi ou l'osce est généralement
que ce soit m nous sommes dit occuper
qu' il y a des temps forts et des temps
faibles dans la journée ses temps forts
la plupart du temps se trouve c'est tous
les enfants le l'après-midi eux le matin
par l'ons dans la deuxième partie de
matinée et 1 12 est bien moindre pour
les plus âgés enfin la police est
important pour les nouveaux aménagements
c'est la question à quel moment va
placer des activités complémentaires
bon en sachant que celle utilisée qu on
peut noter à ne sont pas les
apprentissages de base
voilà un bon bref
et donc on trouve souvent cela on l'a
trouvé comment bien en faisant passer
des tests psychotechniques très bref
parce qu'il faut pas occuper tout
lorsque les reins avec ça avec plusieurs
de prise de mesures par jour avec des
observations avec aussi une concordance
de c
moment folle ce moment fel avec les
travaux de chronologie qui montre que on
est fatigués plus on est plus fatigué
entre guillemets fatigué parce que c'est
un concept difficile à définir le matin
et en début d'après midi que en fin de
matinée bien que là aussi il ya beaucoup
de nuances apportées par rapport à cette
coupe que je vous présente maintenant là
il s'agit d'un exemple parmi tant
d'autres de courge aussi qu'aux
techniques le dialecte de celle de devis
en avoir dans cette expérimentation 120
avec un test alors ce qui a précisé qu'
entre les quatre points de mesures qui
sont on a mis un point central 1 8 et 2
840 11h20 13h40
16h20 c'est bon c'est quel point de
mesure il y a eu des mesures de prises
dans d'autres expériences entre 840 et
11h20 parce que sinon ça voudrait rien
dire
cette co donc on voit bien que ces trois
épreuves ya ce fameux pic de fin de
matinée de deuxième partie de la matinée
et a devrait voire bien moins il s'agit
de celle de la deuxième pic mais qui a
une nuance c'est que cette courbe
évoluent avec l'âge c'est le corps est
vrai et démontrer statistiquement c'est
à dire que quand je vous ai fait ça est
bien c'est qu'il ya une chance sur sur
sao assure mine de sel épandu des
expériences de se tromper en affirmant
que c'était chantillon est représentatif
de la population globale
il faut dire aussi que j'ai bientôt
finies mais demierre réglé faut dire
aussi que lassé d'un point de vue
quantitatif cette courbe il était tout
fier à congeler mise en évidence
j'étais tout à fait une modeste et puis
vous savez les techniques modernes et
vos lois quand j'ai commencé j'avais
déjà d'électricité quand même vous avez
on n'avait pas les banques de données
comme aujourd'hui sur internet et ainsi
de suite
les dans les lits les bibliothèques à
peu près bien équipée comme celle devant
l'université de base celle de tony
stable et c'était les bulletins
signalétique du cnrs et en fouillant
fouilles en demandant des tirs et a
pacifié des photocopies on retrouve des
données des collègues qui s'entend avant
avait travaillé il s'avère que cette
congolaise ce petit poney la met en
évidence un c'est dommage mais c'est un
chercheur allemand qu'il a été le
premier est connu en psychologie et big
boss l'a retrouvé la même avec en plus
une nuance de taille et que j'ai
retrouvé aussi après c'est que cette
cours évoluent avec l'âge elle n'est pas
figée
mais c'est sur c'est ce qu'on retrouve
le plus souvent bon jeu ça a été
retrouvée aussi en angleterre s'était
retrouvé en allant aux états unis au
début du siècle dernier et on n'a pas
été elle sort non plus cocorico
le laboratoire de psychologie fromental
de rennes sous la conduite de bourne on
a trouvé là même qu alors ça s'appelait
pas comme ça ça s'appelait la courbe
déficience intellectuelle
bon c'était on n'avait pas les mêmes
termes et des résultats et ce qui m'a
aussi encouragés à vérifier que cet
homme n'était pas que nos courbes c'est
que
le reflet de courbes biologique mais
bien le coup psychologique preuve en est
c'est cette deuxième courbe là qui
prenons la coupe scal air est basé sur
le concept de proportionnalité en
mathématiques et j'ai toujours le même
exemple ça me permet de pas trop nous
tromper c'est le problème du type ont
évidemment on parle pas de boissons avec
les élèves quelques bouteilles de face
et on peut y aller de bon jury selway ça
va être du bon quand même qu'à bouter le
jury coûte 27 euros combien coûte 12
bouteilles ya deux façons de le faire et
2,3 ou proportion était trois fois plus
cher 12 euros 12 bouteilles 3 x 27 81
vous poser les problèmes de ce type à
des élèves de cm2 qui sont en train et
qui savent faire et bien début de
matinée et à 70%
c'est le 78 un axe désordonnée qui
utilisent cette méthode on l'aura à
bâcher aulas inculquer des dires la
méthode canali qu'élégante bon mais vous
allez 30% il malgré tout il pratique de
l'art est de 3 27 / qu est ce que vous
disent que ça tombe pas juste et on
multiplie par 12 par contre aux fans
matignon les 85% et on descend on
retrouve la même cour mais là d'un point
de vue qualitatif
donc là c'est vraiment du cognitif
on est dans le dur et puis pour
confirmer qu forte et bien nous avons ce
fait des observations clos fait souffrir
mes étudiants et moi même où on observer
grâce à des indicateurs de nos aînés ou
des petits vation de garder l'oeil à ce
contraire et là on voyait bien que les
moments forts sur les mêmes et les
moments faibles sont les mêmes alors ce
qu'il faut dire aussi c'est que quelle
que soit quel que soit le type 2 comment
dire le type d'aménagement du temps sauf
un
les biens sauf un on retrouve cette cour
et ceci nous l'avons vérifié en europe
mais nous l'avons vérifié dans des pays
aussi du moyen-orient bon l'algérie par
exemple vous je travaillais un petit peu
en ce moment
bon on retrouve la même courbe c'est
quand même c'est à dire et ça j'ai
évoqué un cas encore on la retrouve pas
et bien c'est le cas pardon cette courbe
on va revenir tout à l'heure déçu ah ben
oui mais alors là ça va pour ben on va
écouter
je vais vous le dire nos prélèvements
excusez moi on trouve un cas c'est le
cas où
enfin je dirais même 2 où les élèves
sont en semaine de quatre jours sans
accompagnement semaine sèche sans rien
et là eh bien on est très inquiet parce
que non seulement on trouve pas cette
courbe mais en plus les performances des
élèves moyenne de groupe et bien son
lancement inférieur aux autres
par contre et on va le voir tout à
l'heure si vous accompagner cette
semaine de quatre jours d'activités
périscolaires
c'est dire le mercredi est bien où est
le samedi s'il faut et bien on n'a pas
une baisse de niveau mais n'a toujours
une aversion de la réplique cité on
viendra tout à l'heure très vite alors
il faut aussi dire qu'il y ait une
évolution avec l'âge je voulais dit tout
à l'heure vous avez à droite
des élèves de cm2 et on a la coupe
traditionnelle que je vous ai indiqué et
regardez là ce qui se passe pour les
élèves de cp c'est pas du tout la même
coup relève de maternelle c'est pas du
tout la même courbe du tout ce qui veut
dire que l'une des premières mesures à
prendre ultérieurement dans le cadre de
la mise en place de cette réforme est de
de l'ajustement bien ça sera
certainement de tenir compte de l'âge et
c'est ce qui est en train à mon avis de
se faire par une soupe haye
on a essayé de son îlot a essayé de
tenir compte un peu plus de l'âge et on
a bien vu les réactions aussi de
certains parents qui sont je dirais
un peu justifié en disant qu'on peut pas
avoir la même la même application de ces
résultats pour les élèves de maternelle
bien que le reste bon ça se comprend et
puis alors ensuite je voudrais par
rapport à dire aussi que il ya une toile
la troisième variable la toisième
variable à tout dont on loue obtenir
compte c'est les répits cité annuel et
il ya des moments forts des moments
faibles cioni vous l'année et c'est très
curieux c'est l'exemple que je vais vous
donner ce problème des vacances de la
toussaint qui a été vraiment bien bien
permis de repérer comment ça se passe ça
faisait très longtemps je disais aux
vacances à tout ça il faut de ce fait
une semaine comme les autres d'ailleur
moyenne vacances mais pour vraiment
oublier l'emploi du temps de type
scolaire ne plus entendre le réveil
alors qu'il ne sonne plus et puis
l'autre semaine se sentir dans ses
pantoufles de vacances et c'est d'autant
plus important la toussaint que c'est en
plein milieu du trimestre c'est que le
1er mai c'est affreusement long et que
les études épidémiologiques sur les
maladies sur la mort mais ça c'est pour
les adultes et bien montrent que ces
périodes au fin octobre début novembre
est une période difficile à vivre et
s'est renforcée par intérim qui
affreusement long et quand on était en
place à ce jour etc ont récupéré sur les
grandes vacances eh bien on rogner sur
le mois d'août la fin du mois d'août et
on a longé
d'autant premier trimestre ce qui fait
que si un jour c'est une seule hypothèse
l'idée venez au au législateur de
raccourcir les vacances surtout le les
raccourcis c'est pas par fin novembre e
fin août pardon surtout pas ça rallonge
d'autant donc à aubry obtenant de temps
plus court que ces périodes difficiles à
vivre
elle est présente en france mais l'épée
se présente dans tous les pays européens
et voir je parlais tout à l'heure en
algérie ont tous la même chose c'est
assez curieux c'est comme ça bien
ensuite les travaux qu'on peut tirer des
recherches que nous avons menée parce
que je n'ai pas mené des recherches que
sur le terrain les et menées aussi en
laboratoire ou vice versa la boîte est
sur le terrain alors les élèves qui
présentent les plus belles situations à
un vrai régal pour les chercheurs mais
c'est pas l'objet ainsi paul l'objet
n'est pas de se faire plaisir c'est bien
les élèves qui ne maîtrise pas ce qu'il
faut faire
les élèves qui ça fait que ce ses
activités physiques cctv figiefa surtout
psychologique
ils savent tout le temps faire alors on
a aussi montré que l'activité du katy
perry scolaire et extrascolaire
contribuer à l'épanouissement physique
et psychique des jeunes nous avons par
exemple expérimenté sur une ville comme
bourges ou dans une zone d'éducation
prioritaire ou ses enfants qu'on les
accompagne en début d'année et en fin
d'année avec d'autres enfants
dean était hors zones prioritaires
quartier
tranquille entre guillemets eh bien on
voyait bien qu'il y avait quand même des
dix critiques à des dysfonctionnements
au niveau de la réplique cité alors pour
ces élèves de zep
alors que pour les autres bons allait
bien mais et leur niveau en zep était
bien inférieur la municipalité a dit
nous on fait deux après midi par semaine
complète avec des ateliers ouverts à la
participation des enseignants mais aussi
d'animateurs de forme est rémunéré par
la ville sur ce quartier en fin d'année
les anomalies rythmique avait disparu et
les niveaux étaient les mêmes entre les
deux échantillons donc bien on a fait on
a démontré sa plusieurs fois la semaine
de quatre jours c'est qu'il vient
désynchronise la publicité journalières
c'est ce que je vous ai dit tout à
l'heure et affaiblie par de bonnes
performances
enfin et c'est là le bas le problème
important c'est de libérer du temps
n'est pas obligatoirement synonyme
d'épanouissement
c'est là c'est toujours le monsieur là
qu'il disait mais moi je le sais je m'en
fiche
à l'entrée une vie moi je m'en fiche mes
enfants je sais quoi en faire je m'en
occupe
j'ai laissé par ses besoins de
participer aux activités complémentaires
bon et c'est schématiser a quand même
mais vous avez si vous vivez à 8 ans
faut savoir quoi en faire et j'ai été
pendant là c'est mon adversaire un autre
cas cette casquette été pendant douze
ans président national de la jeunesse au
plein air
lorsque réoccuper des loisirs éducatifs
c'était pas pour laisser des enfants
désoeuvrés c'était le pot que leurs
loisirs soit éducatif c'est là aussi le
concept nouveau c'est l'éducation assuré
par tous alors cette maîtrise elle
dépend de qui de quoi bien le dépend du
niveau scolaire des élèves
elle dépend de la difficulté des traces
parce que ceux qui sont bons la qui il
mais on a montré qu'il pouvait aussi fut
tué il suffit de remonter les
difficultés d'exercice ça s'est un peu
sali les conditions d'exécution de la
tâche et dire que si vous êtes en
situation motivante ça va vous
bouleverser vos rides
était là aussi ça pose des problèmes
pédagogiques assez important et puis le
stade d'apprentissage et si on regarde
le papou du stade d'apprentissage voilà
un exemple symptomatique en début la
partie sage des élèves maîtrisent pas ou
ne savent pas faire enfin
l'apprentissage
ils y arrivent la cité sur un exercice
tout bête de de conjugaison des accords
de leurs biens et là qu'est ce qui se
passe
eh bien c'est ce qui se passe quand on
est en quête jours et voilà ce qui se
passe à exige de cp je vous avais dit
qu'il n'y avait pas de reprise
d'activité ou très peu balaïa n'a pas du
tout dans une ville la bleue mais quelle
joie vie mais le niveau largement au
dessus car la bombasse et surtout faut
profiter surtout de la deuxième partie
de la matinée
et puis dans les deux autres grandes
villes sont les grandes villes où les
avis l'activité les jours de classe
normale et il n'y avait rien en dehors
de la classe on se retrouve avec des
couples inversés symptomatique d'une
désynchronisation source de fatigue et
surtout de baisses de résultats
donc voilà ce que nous avons trouvé
alors si vous accompagner comme ce fut
fait dans une ville comme rennes
accompagner le
la semaine et quelques jours avec une
grosse complémentarité l'important
complémentaires et éducative eh bien
vous avez là des niveaux similaires mais
en revanche on retrouve pas la coupe
classique traditionnelle qui pour moi et
pour nous et quand même quelque chose de
très important se dire que les impros du
temps qu'on propose aux enfants sont bon
an mal an les emplois du temps qu'ils
vont bien dans le sens de la réussite et
de l'enfant et de son développement
alors quand on leur laisse du temps
j'explique rapidement de quoi il s'agit
mais vous savez les enfants
d'aujourd'hui leur laisser du temps ils
ont plusieurs possibilités
s'ils ont rien à faire sur les encadrent
pas là en france
je vais prendre la france par exemple
vous avez 7 % des enfants qui les
journaux classe regarde plus de 2h30 la
télévision 12% plus de trois heures
ce qui fait 10 9% super seul et j'avais
pas mis dans le circuit les tablettes
encore dit tous les écrans qui existent
ça sera mon avis je suis largement en
dessous de ce qui se passe tous les
jours de classe en espagne kia ou
l'espagne à des emplois du temps un peu
la ville ont pris le temps un peu
similaire au nôtre où la pause est plus
longue et mais on a quand même 17 % + 2
entend 19% 2
trois heures ce qui fait de 36 pour ça
regardez ce qui se passe dans les pays
consiste souvent face surtout un en
exemple en matière d'aménagement du
temps nos amis allemands à bas nos amis
allemands des sceaux 17% plus de 2h30
27% 3 heures ce qui fait quand même 44%
alors je vous laisse trouver la réponse
1 pourquoi ça se passe comme ça mais bon
j'ai ma petite idée
et bien pour beaucoup d'activités
maintenant 1
c'est le problème encore dans les
conférences que je présente on me dit ah
le modèle allemand formidable alors je
un petit coup de cocorico non attendez
ou oui ils sont pas plus bêtes que nous
ils sont aussi intelligents il réussit
c'est bien beau mais au niveau des
loisirs s'est pas tout à fait ça parce
que en plus ils ont les mêmes tout ou
bien alors les anglais alors là ils sont
les meilleurs
59 % +2 en temps puisque 5% 9 % + 5 ans
c'est énorme
pareil parce que là bas la peau midi
termine plus tôt en plus ça permet donc
voilà on les libère du temps de rentrer
voir comment ça je veux pas trop la
baume
enfin vous m'expliquez monsieur bien
pour terminer moi simplement quelques
recommandations
quand je veux permettraient de formuler
je me suis permis de formuler qui ont
parfois même était pas mal entendu
alléger la journée scolaire
bon je dirais plutôt maintenant
dédensifier parce que il faut bien faire
le distinguo je l' ai dit tout à l'heure
entre activités purement scolaire et
activités complémentaires
bon ça n'a rien à voir à mon avis il ya
il peut y avoir à des rôles et paye à
wall est bon des points de départ du
périscolaire vers le scolaire ou le
contraire du scolaire périscolaire
mais on n'est plus en situation
d'apprentissage poussé on n'est plus en
situation d'apprentissage
j'assiste respectifs prioritairement les
heures et les jours de meilleures
performances
j'ai oublié de préciser est un jour qui
n'est vraiment pas un jour de gloire au
niveau de la réplique cité et au niveau
du de l'enfant au niveau de son
attention ces violences c'est le lundi
il suit le week-end et ça va jusqu'à
mardi midi si le week-end et deux jours
mais ça c'est dans les situations avec
des enfants qui vivent mal le week-end
d'où la nécessité d'avoir une vie
régulière et d'avoir à trail main dans
la main entre parents éducateurs fallu
quatorze animateurs et enseignants
essayé de respecter l'alternance sept
semaines de classe plus de semaines de
vacances cette semaine plus ou moins une
parce que nous avons quand même pas mal
de petites fêtes comme ça qu'ils
viennent de commémoration de victoire
donne tout le temps donc c'est pas trop
je vous ai dit les deux semaines ils
sont importants les sept semaines qui
sont pas dans ses sauts ce sont surtout
les deux semaines les deux semaines qui
permette qu'un joli une semaine pour se
déshabituer du stress parce que c'est
vrai que nous élèves sont stressés et
une autre semaine pour se sentir dans
ses pantoufles de vacances et éviter
l'aspect rickshaw et maintenir la
sereine qu'elle joue ennemie et là je me
lancerai pas à titre de chercheur sur le
débat samedi matin ou mercredi matin
si vous me demandez je vous dirais
quelle est ma position un protocole est
pas écouté fouet essayer de développer
les structures les activités éducatives
complémentaires de l'école j'ai pas me
créer à tout prix
l'idéal ça serait créé et développé ou
bon bref mettre des deux mais j'ai mis
pour le moment développer ou soutenir
avant et ensuite un mot je tairai sûr
cela qui me paraît très important c'est
d'avoir une vie à la régulière
essayez que les enfants ne soient pas
perdues par les ans à cause d'emploi du
temps compliquée à cause de parents qui
veulent trop en faire ou pas ou qui n'en
font pas assez fin bref essayer que la
vie soit non pas un long fleuve ce soit
long fleuve tranquille et je vous
remercie de frais de cette tension
non monsieur testud merci infiniment de
cette présentation scientifique mais
également pragmatique des parquets les
les recommandations que vous nous avez
présenté je vais immédiatement donné la
parole à madame le rapporteur qui à
quelques questions vous posez dont celle
de votre préférence du mercredi et du
samedi
donc voyez en beauté les guides même les
questions mais oui merci beaucoup pour
votre présentation
moi je vais revenir et les questions
vendre découler vous avez dit et on en a
bien conscience que il n'y a pas de
solution idéale
alors sachant qu'il n'ya pas de solution
idéale mais on a vu un certain nombre de
deux graphiques
alors il n'y a pas de solutionner al
donc je pose de suite la question
de madame la présidente quand on pense
qu'on a sous les yeux régularité dans la
semaine comme ça une béotienne on peut
penser que le samedi matin
ça met plus de régularité on a deux un
deux et demi 1 et on a bon moins de
coupures le week-end
donc ça je m'interroge deuxième deuxième
interrogation au vu de certaines certain
nombre de mises en place et d'expérience
on voit que dans un certain nombre de
communes a été choisi d'arrêter
les enseignements le vendredi à 14h à
14h30
alors certes on met d'étape mais comme
c'est libre dans les faits avec des élus
qui nous disent a baissé de correspond à
la demande des parents donc comme ça ils
partent mieux en week end et le vendredi
donc par rapport je le relis par rapport
à votre alternance et votre rythme là on
serait peut-être enfin on doit être en
plein air cruises mais en pleine
contradiction d'avoir peut-être rajouter
une matinée de mercredi mission allège
le vendredi dès 15 heures
d'après vos travaux ce bénéfice doit
être nul je me pose la question
sauf que c'est une tendance
c'est une tendance ensuite par rapport
aux graphiques au mot on voit bien qu'il
ya une baisse de mémoire de 13 heures 13
heures 20 jusqu'à 15 heures ou au ça
repart or là ou alors là aussi peut-être
que moyennant les activités scolaires
comme aide les enseignants parce que
beaucoup vous le savez se sont opposés à
un allongement de la pause méridienne
parce que certaines équipes
s'appuyant sur ce ce type de deux
constats que vous avez fait on dit ben
voilà on va allonger la pause méridienne
et on reprendra 15 heures pour deux
heures d'enseignement quand ils seront
les plus réceptifs bien
donc tout ça ce sont les questions que
l'on se pose parce que et ensuite je
vous ai entendu parler de l'expérience
de rennes où là vous avez parlé de
deux après midis libérer une heure ou un
peu plus alors non rage alors j'ai mal
compris nom est pardon
donc on a aussi voilà parce qu'on a
aussi je crois que c'était aussi lille
qui portait sa de concentrer pionnat des
projets qui aujourd'hui se dirige vers
pour expliquer que pour mettre en place
des activités complémentaires
suffisamment structurée qui prennent en
compte parfois des déplacements il vaut
mieux libérer deux fois une heure et
demie dans la semaine que quatre fois
trop quart d'heure donc on peut
l'entendre par rapport à une
organisation mais par rapport au nez
quand même le but dans cet aménagement
de la semaine scolaire c'est de faire
que nous soyons plus en phase avec
justement les rythmes des enfants donc
parfois j'ai l'impression qu'on navigue
dans des contradictions et donc voilà
les questions que j'avais souhaité poser
merci beaucoup madame un rapporteur mais
c'était su si vous me le permettez nous
reste que qu'une dizaine de minutes
et oui bien sûr mais j'ai également un
monsieur de lège qui souhaiterait vous
posais une question si vous en est
d'accord monsieur n'ont pas forcément
bien donc monsieur roger non plus une
petite question et le droit à la paresse
voilà ça c'est la question de monsieur
roger de ce testud la parole et havret
est à vous board bien je vais essayer
d'être bref pour pouvoir laisser la
place à d'autres
effectivement je confirme et je persiste
et signe il n'y a pas de solution idéale
mais il ya quand même des erreurs à
éviter des erreurs assez importante et
vous m'avez cité une erreur elles contre
laquelle je m'insurge
vous avez bien compris c'est à dire de
libérer par exemple vendredi après-midi
et de libyens aussi le samedi parce
qu'effectivement
le vendredi après midi et comment dirais
je
si si vous n'y verrez pas si vous faites
la casse ce samedi matin d'accord mais
ça pas l'air d'être le cas dans le
canton propose le vendredi après midi
bon c'est à mon avis la plus mauvaise
des solutions
au moins là je suis claire
et pourquoi vous l'avez dit tout
simplement parce que le les activités
commerciales ne sont pas obligatoires
l'après midi
donc vous avez certains enfants de
milieux complètement posée d'ailleurs
ceux qui pourront partir avec leur part
en bon accord
wouah week-end mais cela le week end va
pas trop les produits à la hauteur du
kilomètre qui vont avaler ou des
situations parce que c'est souvent
l'argument qui avance et ces familles
séparées ou l'enfant va voir son papa et
sa maman femme a fait des tirs et il est
bien c'est parfois mais et puis vous
avez les autres enfants il représente
quand même un certain non ce qui fait
quand justement les zones dites
sensibles entre guillemets et qui comme
c'est pas obligatoire et comme il n'y a
pas la motivation des rebelles ils
n'iront pas ses activités
alors c'est et puis prolongée le
week-end de en définitive d'une demi
journée ça va faire un week-end de deux
jours et demi non seulement ça va se
répercuter jusqu'au mardi minée on mardi
soir vers vous vous vous perdez tous vos
efforts la non là mon avis cette seule
l'erreur principale à éviter alors
ensuite jeu
vous m'avez un petit peu poussée dans
mes retranchements pour le samedi matin
ou mercredi matin
bon c'est vrai que la solution du samedi
matin d'une solution plus régulière bon
et je pense que bon je prends ma langue
dans ma poche si j'ai toujours dit que
je préférais l'écrit le samedi matin
mais je n'ai pas voulu en parler de
gérer tout simplement parce que mes
résultats scientifiques ne sont pas
aussi clair qu'on veut bien le dire
c'est à dire qu' il n'y a pas cet
incident sur les résultats s'est tenue
et la significativité statistique et
n'est pas suffisamment importante pour
dire pour choisir le solde est donc ce
d'autant plus qu'il ya un problème d'âge
les petits ils allaient à l'école le
samedi matin le mercredi matin toute
façon faut qu'ils se lèvent le mercredi
matin
donc ça change pas grand chose par
contre pour les plus âgés de cm2 ce que
sous sa gelée vieille fille et une
tendance à ce que le samedi matin soit
préférable ou mercredi matin à la police
que le mercredi est toujours ses fans et
des activités complémentaires comme il y
avait autrefois mais bon je jouais pas
m'accrocher à ça comme le bernica son
rocher parce que je pense que vous
parlez le pragmatisme ça fait partie du
palmah dix mains parce que quand on
compare samedi matin mais collimateur
d'une manière globale on est où la
licité il n'y a pas de défi de
désynchronisation comme on aurait pu le
penser à un moment c'est pas le cas
alors aussi à la solution qui est
souvent avancé libre deux fois par
semaine elle avoir une réponse un peu
c'est bien fait mais dont je crois que
ces personnes qui avant était du côté de
la normandie mais c'est en touraine
c'est pareil on est bon on fait paraît
bien ça dépend de l'environnement
s'il faut aller à un endroit trop loin
par rapport à l'école
effectivement il faut prévoir un peu de
temps parce que si vous mettez que trois
quarts d'heure trois quarts d'heure le
le comment dire tous les jours c'est
bien ça ça etc c'est loin ça va être
juste
donc la fois savoir tenir compte de ça
il ya aussi un problème de régularité a
regagné solution enfin la solution qui
j'ai rien compter d'aujourd'hui sur les
deux après midi j'ai rien contre
à la condition que ça ça s'enchaîne bien
mais est que ce soit lié à des
contraintes il ya des contraintes
environnementales qu'on peut pas écarter
surtout quand on est en place
alors la solution de la pause bien il me
semble une solution tout à fait
défendable d'ailleurs spontanément les
collègues
dans pas mal d'endroits on a envisagé un
allongement de la pause méridienne et ça
pose pas de problème et je dirais mon
avis c'est pas ça j'ai peut-être un peu
plus tôt le soir bon d'accord mais c'est
pas c'est parce qu'on a eu on perd pas
de père pas le bénéfice en plus de la
possibilité d'un deuxième pic d'après
midi moi je pense que l'un en plus en
prenant la pause moyenne pour les
tout-petits et règle le problème
ça sent d'ailleurs imposé là c est le
repos 2010 du repos postprandiale non je
sais c'est à mon avis une solution alors
la condition bien évidemment que les
enfants se retrouvent à condition que
les enfants et leurs leurs repères et
que ce soit là aussi régulier moi j'ai
pas ce que c'est c'est un peu comme dans
le temps quand on a vu les personnaliser
on sait pas où mettre le personnaliser
ce n'était pas facile mais là c'était du
scolaire proprement dit tandis que je
dis pas qu'on fait rien j'ai dirigé les
centres de vacances mais c'était un
moment idéal en plus
on voyait les enfants ils prenaient leur
rapport et puis après mais ça j'ai du
temps libre et j'avais c'est bon alors
pour poser d'activité galles ou alors
proposé par faouët on peut très bien
aménagé ça au moment de la pause mais
bon bref
et c'est peut-être de la solution la
plus simple vous avez l'air d'abonder
mais bon alors est ce que j'ai répondu
alors le droit à la paresse
j'ai fait partie de ces enfants qui
étaient passés très courageux niveau le
travail scolaire
sam hamad bref je pense qu'il faut que
les enfants de temps en temps il est là
on leur met pas tout le temps tout dans
la pression et qu' il puisse faire ce
qu'ils ont envie de faire mais quand
même en leur inculquant le fait qu'il
faut travailler en on rien n'arrive à
moins d'être surdoué est là il son
travail mais bon le droit le droit de le
s'ennuyer c'est aussi ça existe à petite
dose le droit les paresseux petite pause
le droit de se révolter à petites doses
très bref
mais je suis je pense que ce que voulais
te dire c'est que je ne sais pas c'est
arrêtons de leur mettre la pression sans
arrêt et là aussi c'est c'est un point
qui me surprend c'est les parents qu'ils
aient déjà les dernières avaient proposé
à leurs enfants de nombreuses activités
et qui comme en cette année en de
nouvelles activités offertes la plupart
du temps on les fait aussi s'il fait que
vous avez un surbooking qui existait
déjà dans certaines familles mais alors
là les amplifier il faut faut savoir le
gérer
moi je vois les des enfants le mercredi
parfois mais c'est là c'est dur là moi
je vous rejoins pour le genre merci
beaucoup mais c'est testud pour
l'ensemble de vos réponses très
argumenté je crois que madame le
rapporteur vous aviez encore une
question non
je crois qu'on peut s'en arrêter là
puisqu'on dit les 29 oui non moi je
rebondis sur le droit à la paresse et
comment arriver à faire passer le
message aux parents puisqu'on le voit
aujourd'hui dans la mise en place des
rythmes il développe une exigence de
compétences dans l'encadrement d'
pour laquelle je pense que là on est à
l' inverse de ce qu on souhaiterait
excuse moi je reprend la parole après
vous ça se fait pas oui monsieur ce qui
est symptomatique c'est ce qui se
passera à 2 2 fait symptomatique par
rapport à ce que vous dites c'est ce qui
se passe en maternelle où les parents
eux mêmes dit il n'ont pas à dormir faut
pas qu'ilan ça c'est clair
voilà ça mais ça c'est le premier
argument
le deuxième c'est de dire ils sont pas à
l'école parce que c'est l'école pour
dormir alors si c'est ça
faudra quand même temps quand on
expliquer par exemple que certaines
entreprises qui cherchent la pollution
qui cherche le résultat propose
maintenant le sommet à leurs employés
bon bref et le deuxième exemple je n'ai
perdu donc à l'actrice qui était
symptomatique de se mesurer à six et de
son book inn du mercredi nous on perd
complètement l'objectif c'est dommage
enfin se trouve t eu un grand pas de
fait vous savez entre ce qu'on a connu
en matière d'aménagement du temps où les
impôts lutteurs étaient imposés face au
soir faisait déjouer pas voulu vous le
faire parce que vous connaissez par
coeur historique d emploi du temps
français et que c'est bien la première
fois et c'est un mouvement de fond
toutes tendances confondues qu'on se
préoccupe dans les nouveaux aménagements
du temps des enfants des jeunes
voyez pas que les enfants le châtel s'en
est occupé
le relais a été pris par vincent peillon
la commission parlementaire moi j'étais
très intéressé par les faits rapporte
que vous avez brut bienvenue à tous pour
ce grand débat d'avant premier tour des
municipales un débat consacré à
montreuil en seine saint denis ce débat
diffusé sur france 3 ile de france et
france bleu 107 1 dont les auditeurs
vous connaissent bien nous aider silva
puisque vous assurer chaque matin
l'interview politique
un débat qui est également diffusé sur
public sénat michaël szames s
journaliste de la chaîne regarde
actuellement cette émission dans les
coulisses il viendra dans les cinq
dernières minutes exercé à un droit de
suite et peut-être demander des
explications si jamais quelques points
n'avait pas été très très clair les
lecteurs de métro news ont également
adressé des questions nous les
relèverons pour alimenter le débat bien
évidemment les lecteurs qui peuvent
suivre sur les sites internet de tous
les médias partenaires cette émission
leur noé nous avons choisi montreuil
pour deux raisons c'est l'une des villes
les plus peuplées d'île de france autour
de cent mille habitants à l'est de paris
une ville qui a une identité très forte
mais inquiet aussi des problématiques
communes à toutes les grandes villes de
la petite couronne qui jouxte le tout
paris
mais c'est aussi une ville politique
avec un scénario atypique originale la
gauche mais